олесій Гончаренко з брифі оголосив про
те що значить через 15 років Україна не
зможе платити пенсії пенсіонерам
українським Ну по-перше я хочу одразу
тут прокоментувати знаєте Поки ви не
прийшли до влади і оці всі перший уряд
Зеленського другий уряд Зеленського
Україна якось могла виплачувати пенсії
може не високі і Звісно що важливо щоб
вони були більшими Але такого щоб
ставити питання Що Україна взагалі не
здатна сплачувати пенсії Ну це
результати вашого дування звичайно коли
в нас ВВП падає в другому кварталі на
11,5% Уявіть собі дев'ята частина
економіки держави зникла причому
посилання на ковід щоб ви розуміли в
Італії яка там весь світ чув про те як
вона потерпає від коронавірусу падіння
менше суттєво менше ніж в Україні в якій
розповідали нам Зеленський що він
майстер спорту по боротьбі з
коронавірусом Але там є ще і друга
частина у заяві шмигаля на яку я хотів
би звернути вашу увагу він каже і вихід
з цього питання по пенсіях один це
вводити другий рівень накопичувальний це
є абсолютно нормально але який значить
обов'язковий з тим щоби в 21-му році вже
почав з'явився новий вид виплат і
фактично щоби зарплати кожного українця
примусово забиралися гроші на оцей
другий накопичувальний рівень пенсійного
забезпечення і ось тут я хочу від імені
нашої політичної сили і свого особисто
висловити категоричну незгоду тому що
так має бути накопичувальний рівень але
абсолютно добровільний ті люди які
хочуть накопичувати собі на старість це
є нормально і держава має створити
систему і забезпечити щоб вони могли це
робити але робити це примусово забираючи
в вчителя лікаря працівника ще й ту
частину їхньої невеличкої зарплати яку
вони отримують на те щоби колись Може
бути їм хтось щось виплатить або ці
гроші десь вкрадуть або ці гроші з'їсть
інфляція або ще щось відбудеться от з
цим ми погодитись не можемо і це означає
просто знову все зробити за рахунок
населення Ми і так бачимо підходи цього
уряду коли перед днем вчителя уряд
заморожує зарплати вчителям черговий раз
переносячи е виконання статті 61ї про
три мінімальні зарплати оклад вчителя на
тепер вже 22-й рік перший раз це зробив
рік тому перший уряд Зеленського тепер
це робить другий уряд Зеленського тепер
вони посилаються на коронавірус А що
було рік тому і коронавірусу ще не було
а замороження вже було в таких умовах ще
вводити додаткові платежі зарплати з
невеликої і так зарплати українців це є
неприпустимо друга тема і щодо якої Я
хотів би сьогодні повідомити вас шановні
українці партія європейська Солідарність
отримала ось такого листа який прийшов
наїм ім'я лідера нашої партії Петра
Порошенка значить прощо підписано воно
тво начальника головного управління СБУ
служби безпеки України в Донецькій та
Луганській областях такий Пан русінов і
про що це Про що цей лист вони просять
надати перелік кандидатів від вашої
політичної партії в депутати міських
сільських селищних районних рад а також
міських сільських селищних голів
Донецької област
З вказівкою населеного пункту та району
додатково необхідно надати коротку
характеристику та докладні біографічні
дані на кожного кандидата від вашої
політичної партії поряд з цим просимо
надати інформацію відносно об'єму
витрачених коштів на передвиборчу
кампанію кожного кандидата а також
джерела їх походження от Уявіть собі
такого листа ми
отримали Ми отримали його на електронну
пошту Але ми зв'язалися з управлінням
служби безпеки України в Донецькій і
Луганській областях нам підтвердили
існування листа тут є номер Дата все є
нам підтвердили існування такого листа
підтвердили що пан русінов працює в
цьому управлінні Ну і тоді ми хочемо
повідомити Наступне Що це є абсолютно
категоричне порушення Закону України ми
розцінюємо це як тиск на нас як на
опозиційну політичну силу чому саме на
нас Ну може саме тому що наша партія є
ініціатором створення тимчасової слідчої
комісії повагнергей в якому може бути
замішено і керівництво СБУ України бо
воно володіло цією інформацією і про
спецоперацію яка була зірвана яка була
злита російським спецслужбам я звертаюсь
особисто до пана баканова Я розумію що
ви друг брат сват там кум сусід
однокласник Зеленського але крім всього
цього ви ще є посадова особа найвищого
рангу фактично в Україні і ви маєте
керуватися законами України а не
політично логікою і доцільністю і тут є
тільки два варіанти Перший варіант Це
свідома ваша команда здійснювати тиск на
нашу політичну силу як опозиційну
політичну силу і Другий варіант що це
Вибачте якийсь ідіот який працює у вас
робить такі речі от з цим ви маєте
розібратися ми вимагаємо негайного
службового розслідування і публічного
повідомлення нам що це було хто це
зробив і якщо це просто дійсно
хтось не з ваш наказу і не з наказу
керівництва порушив закон то тоді ця
людина має понести відповідну
відповідальність перед законом і ми
хочемо почути результати службового
розслідування в інакшому випадку це
прямий тиск на опозиційну політичну силу
якою є європейська Солідарність на
головну в Україні опозиційну силу до
діючої влади і в я і в цьому тиску як ми
бачимо може бути використана в тому
числі Служба безпеки України Тож ми ми
Очікуємо на реакцію пана баканова голови
СБУ на оцей абсолютно зухвалу чи то
провокацію чи то дійсно тиск на
опозицію я дякую вам за увагу якщо в
шановніх колег журналістів є питання
готовий відповісти на
них дякую